cop yourselves one of those it's worth
it i promise
you promised you heard it here first
folks kid promises you know
is that a kid guaranteed no that's
that's gonna get you in trouble here uh
but regardless whether you guys get in
shirts or not uh you know because and i
do mean this we did sell out at the king
and the law shirts those are the first
ones that we released uh we people could
not get the size they were gone for a
while they finally came back in that's
why they're available again now so
if you guys are interested in those
shirts at all now is the time to get
them because i promise you they will be
gone again and
they're probably out of your size
probably you probably have to check to
find out if that's even available to you
uh but yes the matchup that we have
coming up let's talk about this one
right we got jules going up against rgn
of course rgn with the akuma who is
jules gonna use
uh you know what i'm not even gonna try
to guess here but of course
goes for the uh the most comfy pick that
he can possibly get it's the gin so um
fun fact jules former teammate in omega
uh jason
he you know he used to be an akuma main
so he does have a bit of experience here
and the fact remains that pika also has
been trading with the kuma so jules can
get some experience in so let's see if
jules's training pays off here in game
one
what the heck that didn't reach
that's pretty wild that's the sixth
start of the round strat for nakuma
player uh but you know historically jen
has always been a good character choice
against the kuma just because he can
carry the demon flip options so uh we'll
see how that comes into play here as
this match progresses obviously
if you're playing these characters you
know this matchup and you know it from
both sides
for sure and now jules is trying his
best to keep rgn at the wall here by
sidestepping realigning himself rgn
looking for ff4s but not getting any of
those and jules though playing a bit
more patient compared to what you've
seen him in the past few games
yeah that was a really nice size of left
there but gets caught can we convert the
combo smart
yeah you know our dad has been driving
up thomas today that he wouldn't have
had enough damage otherwise unless he
spent the rage art there so hit him with
the region the aging demon and sealed
the deal first round rgn two
yeah that was super unfortunate for
jules because as soon as he uh canceled
to zenshin stance after f4 he put
himself so close to rgn to the point
that he got the down three opportunity
in so rgn very smart decision making
[Music]
now that put rgn at such an such a
difficult position to be in and he's
also so close to rage right now he
spends his meter jules is outside her
base now rgn is put there one more hit
tries to go for the dp jules reads it
and takes back round two
that was such a stable right just to
stand there and let that dp fly up like
no
not even on my level kid
okay all right let's see if things can
change a little bit here now
luca looking a little bit different this
time around
a lot
goes for the wall carry combo rgn sold
posted wall also trying to get away from
it but jules a bit early on the call
there gets caught by the mid rgn drops
the comma on the last hit
what timing on that frame kick they're
back we're not going to be enough to
kill backs away back to one again too
far that time
oh what a side
opportunity to punish here rgn's just
one hit away jules is gonna compete
right choice if he wants to close this
one out he does he does have neither oh
jules
wastes the opportunity to close things
out maybe hesitated for a second there
and rgn
and jules is not happy with it
no sir i mean he overheaded like crazy
like all you're trying to do is forward
four repeatedly that's a counter tool
it's not like a round ending tool right
and it's so easy to step uh and you know
he had him dash his face like a single
jab keep out might have been all he
needed right so
really unfortunate there but doesn't
matter right now jules big lead but oh
boy i might have spoke too soon
oh my goodness
i'd have rip
not looking good for jules right now rjn
has rage jules is one hit away from rage
also he gets that down three and rgn
closes it the same way he did tomorrow
rgn with game one in this best of five
set
yeah and you know i was talking about
the parry that jin has in this akuma
matchup
not being used currently right a lot of
the demon flip options are working uh a
lot of them are landing and you know gin
windows characters that doesn't really
have to deal with it right he can either
parry or even his magic four is like the
screw attack out of the air uh so he has
a couple of options including uh most
characters do just a sidewalk right uh
sidewalk and block but right now the
demos are really really paying off uh
for rgn uh you know we'll see
what changes come this way right now but
it's not looking good for jewels the
only good news for him is that this is a
first to three set this is loser's final
best of five the whole way through here
uh so anything can happen we'll see
not over yet yeah there's a lot of a lot
of opportunity for jules to adjust here
a lot of opportunities to also download
uh his opponent
reminder that jules has a lot more
experience in the bag
compared to rgn so he might use that
experience
against him so you know jules might make
the switch here maybe go for the bob
this time uh jin doesn't really look
like it's working out but if if he does
stick with jin he does have another
chance to switch the job if he uh switch
to the bob if he loses
yeah we saw the switch to bob in the
winner's final against ak after being
down 2-0 and that at that point you know
it was working but it's too late right
so
uh hopefully the same thing doesn't
happen here
we'll see what he wants to do here
or how he does how he approaches the
matchup
uh if it's so if it's any different from
the way we saw in the first games
let's see what has changed already for
jules goes for more low pokes this time
he realizes that rgn doesn't really
block any of those as soon as i said it
i know right
just to make us look bad nice punish
that time all right can cans there for
the tatsu wall carry easy here for gin
[Music]
i think the scariest thing about these
four
yeah that's the scary part right rgn
when he has a life deficit he's unafraid
to just go in right now and jules is
kind of terrified to close things out
and he's almost at a full bar here smart
all right
round two now that's the better
that's true it's it's so risky for jules
to go for a low here because he knows
akuma can kill you with one combo even
if it's a low parry uh so you know jules
is playing this one out more safe than
usual rgn's just taking advantage of
that right now
yeah but once akuma has meter too you
also don't want him to just run up on
you right because the mix becomes a
little bit too scary to deal with then
because a quick down three and you could
lose half your life real fast
punishes also the sidewall saves his
life though jules good luck on the low
what's the choice going to be rgn f3
closes it up
yeah i'm a little bit nervous the jewels
right now
arjun in the matchup just looks a little
bit more comfortable to me
oh if that was electric electric but he
missed it by just a bit rgn
try to go for more offense here but
jules so far cannot find any openings
yet
he's trying he's got a spot lightly
though running three no go
oh boy
that's huge all right rgn probably gonna
knock him in the rage no okay well now
he's not ready that's gonna be enough
damage
calculated there by rgn
yeah jules struggling
to get the offense in for rgn because
the more he approaches rgn the more he's
susceptible to down three combos
especially the fact that he's already at
another meter good rick punished by
jules and now he's got the momentum in
toe kick does not stop his momentum but
the dp will
yeah in that first game we saw him wait
for it this time rgn
letting it rock
and uh oh here comes the downforce nice
2-1 check and that's such a good choice
from jinder right like that's much
harder for akuma to deal with when he's
trying to rush it on you and down three
yeah for sure and jules again has to
take into account the down three and he
has full bars of meter our g i'm gonna
carry to the wall my goodness look at
that wall no
that could have been way worse he got
very lucky there
down three fireball too far that time
the wall here dash all the way to get
the full combo beautiful executes from
rgn and that will be a perfect to close
out game number two rgn just needs one
more game and he's going to the grand
finals of the top two finish guaranteed
that's two games straight for rgn in
this best of five set jules has one more
chance
to take this and come back from it this
is not looking good for uh for our iron
wall of defense this jewels on mega
jewels
can rgn make such a dark horse play and
tell this story to all the viewers out
there that he can go toe-to-toe against
the top players in the philippines
that would be amazing right then you
know the one big thing that i'm noticing
so far in these first couple games you
know jules has the life leads right he's
had multiple rounds of life leads and as
soon as that happens in this rage mode
for rgn he's got a little bit of meter
he just starts folks attack dash
canceling forward he's like i'm gonna do
this and you're gonna let me and that's
what's happening jules is letting him
just control the pace of that right
because he's scared and then because you
can't tilt the timing fit the down three
becomes more unpredictable he's fine the
down threes and in that case full combo
extended he didn't need to do the fadc
there right he could have killed him
without the fdc commenting document he
just done a simple one-time
balcony break then downstairs screw
attack range whatever phrase right but
he went for the full-time he's so
confident right now that's scary right
arjun is playing very loose right now
he's very very comfortable even when
he's about to die each round which is
the worst thing for jules right now and
the question right now obviously he's
tried two games with jim we saw him
switch to bob before does he switch to
bob here
you know i i think uh mahant tells me
that he's gonna switch for the bob
because
if
jin hasn't been working like at all
and jules also struggles with closing
the rounds out he might need to
give out the same energy you know give
out the the same type of riskiness that
rgn is playing uh with um with jules's
bob gameplay so we're gonna see that in
just a few moments boys and girls are we
gonna see a character switch or are we
seeing the gin but no marduk instead is
chosen by jules
wow
this is a big switch up and i like it
marduk is a crazy character
uh in this game right now
you know we definitely see him
i don't want to say that he's
underrepresented
but he's definitely better than you
expect
put it that way
push guaranteed why who cares
mixed
away from the wall though here we go rgn
guessing the mix-ups gets wrong and rgn
gets low buried in we see wall no we
will not
oh everything was looking so good jules
you have such a big life lead
[Music]
all right
maybe just a bit of a shaky start for
jules here now he just needs to close
this one round out rgm throws out the
hadouken
okay down three spends the fadc 10
seconds left jules has a rage rgn gotta
be super careful here what will yours
what are you gonna do what
back up back up
all right all right jules on the board
first here held on to a round with the
life lead
nicely done
talking about damage look at martic yeah
not the cleanest round but it does work
here we go jules
immediately
for the well-standing launcher he's not
he's not happy about the previous
results rip he wants them back he wants
them points back
you said not a clean round like watts is
perfect immediately afterward
oh my goodness everything is landing
counter hit right now get in this air
back this way i don't think so
bro if he loses this round though you
know
i don't think he'll get out of the air
stupid ass 2d character just a jab
you cursed it
damn man martic is a great choice martik
is a fantastic i like that
he has so many just hits that it's like
i'm just gonna throw it out there and if
it hits you fine if it's not i don't
care you know like if you're concerned
about an akuma fad seeing up to you and
around it down through you just throw
out a down back too with martic what's
the worst that could happen you know
what i mean you just get a hit counter
it may be regular hit otherwise they're
going to block it and nothing's going to
happen you're the same position you were
before anyway uh i like to kick i like
to pick a lot so good stuff jules
yeah i've seen i've commentated so many
of jules's games already to point out
that he plays so differently uh
comparing it to the gin pick the
martifiq is so different like
he plays aggressively
but it doesn't feel like it you know you
know what i mean it's difficult to
explain it up until you get to to
actually play him
that's what that's what i mean here and
i think that's what rgn is also
struggling with in that round right now
given the fact that he also asked has to
adjust the uh to a new sort of play
style so jules has a really big
advantage here
yeah i mean i think the thing i know
like similar to what you're trying to
say there
i think there's one time where rgn tech
rolled and jules attacked with a while
standing through with mark like on his
tech roll or something it seemed like a
really weird place to put a while
standing three but he just he didn't
want to give up his turn ever he's like
nope i'm going with the big stuff and
i'm not going home with it uh but there
you have it he's on the board now two
games to one rgn needs one more he
prefers the stage not first time we've
seen him pick it
let's see if we can close it out here or
will this martic send us to a final game
in the set
oh there it is on point punished by
jules one two is minus fifteen after all
the jewels with full damage combo
looking forward
spots here rgn's in big trouble so low
in the attack right now he tried to
break but doesn't guess right either
jules one round foot
yeah that was the spear version
down still hoping for a jab started
round didn't find it
but here comes the down fours and the
running three for the mix
oh wow what are we punished by jules rgm
catches him with a down jump drops the
combo though uncharacteristic for rgn
here we go jules presses on the third
hit does have rage try to go with the
wind punishing
oh boy 13 frames oh boy stop by jules
has raged down for to stop him in his
tracks rgn takes it back
i like this look better you know jules
having the life lead and losing to kuma
that one's not worked out for him but
right now when rj is like lead and jules
has rage it's terrifying so i kind of
preferred to be that way jules wants to
win this holy moly that looks so funky
that's true
okay rgn outside of rage good oh good
duck follows up with the combo though
not much damage gonna get out of this
front but he does build up
some meter though down forward one jules
can he close this out yes he can
jewels very impressive momentum fight
that downford one came out of nowhere
and the momentum as you mentioned
clearly on the side now the downforce
for the whip punish even block the down
three
and there goes one bar rj still has the
bar to make this comeback happen though
the jewels can't get
goes for the stop and the gut kick
jules takes it to a final
game now this i like to see this is a
different kind of jewels and i love it
completely different this is so much
better for this matchup than his gin was
right and his gym you know it hadn't
really seemed on point right you started
the electrics weren't really there when
you tried to do them he got the windy
versions etc uh but the mark everything
is there right like martin doesn't have
that execution barrier that the gym
connect if you have an off day with your
execution you don't have to worry about
that as much as marduk you know uh like
you can hit the wrong button the right
things will come out it's amazing it's
he's a great girl
um
and sometimes you do things and you're
like i didn't mean to counter hit that
fantastic you know lo i'm just trying to
low poke boom
out of your health it's exactly what i
intended to do i'm martic
i i got a friend who's a mardic man when
he tackles somebody he just mashes the
hell out of one two and just hopes for
the best i love it i love not afraid
yeah that's amazing it's amazing
that's that dude if i if i was a martic
man that's what i would do i would just
tackle them and i would match the punch
because if i don't know what's happening
you don't know what's happening you know
what i mean how are you going to break
it you can't read me because i can't
read me i'm just hitting the button
that's the best strategy mark man that's
martic mentality right there
martik mentality 101
it's the
the omega male grind set right there
here we are at souk though
rgn
chooses the stage this time the smallest
stage in the game
and it's to be the final game here in
the set losers final who's gonna go into
the top two somebody's going home with
third place here
uh and the martic has been working i'm a
little bit scared for our generation i
was scared the other way around before
but now things have definitely turned
am i going to root for a coup over
mardick no i don't know i don't think i
can do it nope
very
see it's it's conflicting to a lot of
people in the chat also so don't worry
about it rg endo
trying to be in tip-top shape this is
the final game
what the hell
okay jules eating a lot of these pokes
right now
does have rage this time
rgn up against the wall
there it is rgn closes it up with a down
four
there very solid
oh yeah here we go
now we have not seen comments like this
from rg to be honest
like they're like the bread and butter
staples but he hasn't really had a
chance to land them
nice block
what a block and punished by jules rgn
again has to guess right here he's he's
always left at a guessing game when it
comes to jules's juices mardup
and that was such a good choice for the
power quest that jules threw out a
second ago right because he's gonna
leave martin grounded anyway oh my
goodness just get the count right here
to the wall we go
jules answering back now
i don't know if that grav was
intentional throws out a high and arjun
gonna make him pay here he's got rage
he's gonna have a bar here too
yeah i gotta be super careful here she
leads jules out of rage also he spends
it no clean hit one more mixer could do
it rg and kenny close it up yes he can
potential final round for rgn can jules
come back from this boys and girls
he's fought all the way back here would
be a shame for him to go out here coming
so close but rgn trying to steal it
trying to go to the grand finals
even flip palm working out jewels
falling behind but the downfall one
outrages the down four
okay
here's the setup what's the mix-up
doesn't break the throw
what's the mix up here he breaks it okay
good for good for rgn down four after
down four good side step
i'd hold my breath there right now
has to make the right decisions here
no counter at that time
right now i don't know what's gonna
happen
the downfall
against jules and eliminates him from
the tournament and will be meeting ak in
the grand finals congratulations to rgn
exactly rgn well played you know things
were falling apart to that martic he had
to change things up you know he played a
lot more saw the first two rounds that
got the early lead and he really didn't
let jewels have opportunities to come
back right like that's so scary against
martin uh and jules you know great
joining as well goes out to third place
here tonight but jules you know well
played you know imagine if the martic
started off the set the score may have
been completely different right like uh
the gin just wasn't there for him today
didn't work out in the winner's finals
doesn't work out lose final and with
that duels out at third but rgn will be
advancing to go up against ak
in the grand finals here tonight that's
pretty exciting i didn't expect our
generator's parts this is pretty cool
very very good stuff from rgf
and you know big problems big shout outs
to jules also for making it this far
coming so close to the grand finals and
you know
grand finals here ladies and gentlemen
ak versus rgm these two have played
these two have played against each other
a lot